that actually would be really funny if
somehow Trump ends up the libertarian
nominee and then the Libertarians get
like 43% of the vote and it's like well
the Republicans are gone just that's it
don't worry the Libertarians hate
themselves they hate everybody so they'd
hate Trump plenty but I would think if
the 14th amember could keep him off as a
republican it could just keep him off
General right in in the general election
yeah has that ever happened has has ever
been like a massive right in for a
candidate not at the president there's
like six or there's like six or nine
states that you can't write someone in I
forget what Colorado one of them I'm not
sure but uh someone was tweeting about
it I retweeted it but there's like
something like nine states where you
can't do a right in so that means likely
you know if he's not on the the ballot
that he can't win um at least if he's on
the ballot as a as a republican right I
I just don't see I mean I don't
understand like I said first of all I
don't understand the mechanism because
he hasn't been found guilty of anything